this is one of without a doubt one of
the greatest movies I've ever seen in my
life and I am also telling you don't
watch it and now you're gonna [__]
watch it because you know but
don't it's called speak no evil
I look at the cover it's just like a
a Sunset and there's like shadowy
figures in the distance and I'm like huh
what's this about
so I Google it and I read a Danish
family now I'm I'm already hooked
because those Danes dude the Danish the
Danish people
just already I'm in because it's if this
is a thriller
I love it because Danish people you
don't really think about them being okay
so okay but maybe they're extra weird
with the okay
a Danish family visits a Dutch family
and then I go oh okay in this case
two weirds connect
[Music]
okay
lock it throw it away to get out of the
room I gotta call that guy who's talking
about white dudes in jail taking it up
the anus so I am locked in this room
with the idea of a Danish family going
to visit a Dutch family and I think that
this is a thriller
so I go David found it and he goes what
mine he was probably sleeping because
he's always [__] tired or eating
and I read the rest of the synopsis I
say read this a Daniel family visits a
Dutch family they met on a holiday what
was supposed to be now that's where I'm
cemented
if I see the what was supposed to be in
a title I know [__] goes wrong in a
movie
I know I thought one thing and not only
did I think one thing but the people in
the movie thought one thing and I know
something crazy is about to happen but
the people in the movie don't and I'm a
step ahead of the people in the movie
I know some Secrets right so it says
what was supposed to be an idyllic
weekend slowly starts unraveling as the
Danes start uh as the Danes try to stay
and I gotta click on the thing God damn
it
um as the Danes tried to stay polite in
the face of unpleasantness dude
and I'm just like
but a thriller
I go like this
so this movie is about people
Danish people
this is the tagline this is the synopsis
they chose
the Danes try to stay polite
in the face of unpleasantness
they didn't say
during this harrowing Adventure they
didn't say
from
The Duchess
terrifying them
they said they try to stay polite in the
face of unpleasantness now what is
unpleasantness now I'm thinking what are
the things that are unpleasant bad
breath
uh uh you know
um
nausea
a windows open and it's too cold and you
don't want to get up to close it right
and I'm like
that doesn't sound so great to watch a
movie about
but this is in the Thriller category
so I'm hooked
dude
now you got a Dane
the Dutch and two Americans
sitting pretty dude from jump
so I turn it on
and when I tell you
now I'm watching a movie this is what
the movie's about and I'm not gonna ruin
this movie for you because I guess this
is in a way me reviewing this movie and
I think this is an important thing to
talk about on the podcast I know it's
not just another movie review
but
I'm watching the movie
and it starts with this tone of Terror
right and what I mean by that is it's
just showing a guy at a pool
with his wife and another guy shows up
at the resort and says hey our points to
the chair with the guy's stuff on it and
says can I uh use this chair you're
using it and the guy goes like this uh
yeah you know what uh yeah okay and
takes this stuff off gives the guy the
chair now he obviously didn't want to do
it but he was being polite and
and that's just something that we all
deal with so I go like this oh I'm in
this movie in a way but the music and
the score is music and score that would
be in a horror movie so I'm like
killer though
guys he's asking him for his chair
dude when I and if you're a fan of mine
you know if I see some [__] like this
I'm all in dude right
the movie continues for an hour and a
half
and it's just this kind of [__]
that happens for an hour and 20 minutes
like the girl says she's a vegetarian
and they invite them to hang out with
them later on in the year and they stay
at this cabin with them on holiday and
they're like the first thing they do is
like you got to try this board she's
like no that's okay and he's like nah
try it try it and you basically like you
know it's a suggestion but he's like
kind of force it he's like okay and she
eats it and and this happened for an
hour and a half these weird things that
are happening with the [__] music
that would be in like
you know
sicario not a horror movie but like uh
like that [__]
and I look over to David like 40 minutes
and I'm like and I say to him and I'm on
the edge of my seat I say to him like
why is this
so how is this terrifying nothing is
happening and I'm like scared
and he goes like this
boy I don't know man it's just really
unnerving you know and I was like it is
unnerving he says really unnerving man
and we keep saying it for the next it's
a nerdy man really unnerving I'm like it
is unnerving isn't it and I sit and it's
an hour in the movie and I go like this
this movie
I hope it holds up through the end
because this movie
is if this keeps going it's a
masterpiece
and I'm not dude I don't say movies or
songs or [__] or masterpieces I am so
hooked in on this movie and it's so good
and I relate to it so much but also it's
terrifying and they're just chilling I
don't get it
now I'm not ruining this movie
but an hour and 30 minutes into the
movie
something happens in the movie that's a
scene and it is the most and I say this
not lightly
it is the most horrific thing I have
ever seen in cinema it is so I I dare to
say traumatizing it's so bad for me I'm
42. people get trauma when they're like
four I think it traumatized me I'm 42.
and I go like this yo David hey David
tell me what happens I'm out for about a
minute and a half and he's watching it
he stands up puts his hanger on his head
he goes oh no man oh no and I say what's
happening and he says exactly what you
think's happening man and I say I
actually don't think it's happening
because no movie would ever have this
happening and he says well it's
happening man
and he sits down and I look at his face
before I see the movie and I look and
his face is even whiter than it [__]
is normally and he's from [__] Texas
and I say are you kidding me
I have trauma now
we rode out to the end of the movie and
I did not watch the part that I turned
my hat in and at the end also something
at the end to end something really weird
happens too that I had to turn my head
for a little bit but my point is this I
get mad
I get mad at this movie
because I'm like man I was watching this
whole thing and I was into it and I
don't want to have to see this horrific
thing I'm a dad now I can't watch this
[__]
and I'm mad and then I realize I'm mad
because what the [__] man these people
who are going through all this weird
[__] that should have just [__] said
something they should have left the
[__] house
but I wasn't you know being like a black
person in the movie theater like no
don't go in there I was keeping it
inside
and if they just said something I
wouldn't [__] have to see that
[__] and I'm just so invested man
and maybe black people have it right
dude because they're saying this [__]
and these people got into this
predicament because they weren't saying
[__] they just let [__] happen and keep
happening and that's why this movie is
this [__] most terrifying movie I've
ever seen because these people didn't
didn't
do what they know they should have done
dude
and for that reason this movie is still
one of the best movies I've ever seen in
my entire life
I will say that one scene is so horrific
that I wish I didn't see the movie
that's how that's how horrific that
scene is and this is how good the movie
is and [__] man Kristen Taft drop the
director of this movie you are one
[__] up dude and you know it and you
know what because you made two other
movies that are [__] extremely [__]
up online
and I watched another one too because of
my OCD I had to watch the next one the
next day
and it's called a horrible woman and
obviously you have different shares but
I have to watch it because you know what
I [__] love that movie
I got another one parents it's called
parents and these parents go and they
[__] whatever you [__] look it up
but
that's the scariest thing in life
is not saying and doing the [__] that
you wish you would have done
and that coupled with this Horror made
it I mean this guy the way it unfolds
holy [__] so
I am telling you two things it is
without a doubt and I've sat with this
movie for days already so I know it's
true because usually I don't decide if I
like a movie or not right away I have to
let it sit with me